this was the top of the Empire State
Building recently lit up in our CBS this
morning colors to celebrate our special
partnership as we head back to the
iconic building tomorrow morning you'll
join us I hope as we unveiled the new
18th floor and the completion of what it
was a four year renovation to improve
the visitor experience there Gale
Anthony and I went to new heights and
faced our fears to give you an exclusive
look at the renovations and a tour that
reveals some of the building secrets
some of us actually went to new lows I'm
under the building jeff goldblum will
join tony live up on the 86th floor to
talk about his new projects and what new
york city and the Empire State Building
mean to him Youth poet laureate Amanda
Gorman and musician Jon batiste team up
for a towering performance and we even
go behind the scenes with lin-manuel
Miranda as he films his love letter to
New York City I feel like if you've come
here from somewhere else to get to look
up and see this as a part of your
commute to work or your skyline makes
you feel like
I'm in New York that's so true that's
all part of our special broadcast from
the Empire State Building tomorrow right
here on CBS this morning
you guys had great weather we had great
weather the place looks amazing the view
is incredible you know I just exactly
what lin-manuel Miranda said if you walk
if you grew up in New York and you walk
down the street you see that up there
it's like you feel like it's home coming
in from the airport it's the first thing
you see no it is still a beacon all
these years later it really is I can't
wait to see it